La squalophobie, vous connaissez ?
C'est la peur incontrôlable des requins,
elle touche de nombreuses personnes
et bien souvent des gens qui n'ont
jamais croisé le moindre requin.
Mais cette mauvaise réputation est-elle vraiment justifiée ?
Doit-on considérer les requins comme de dangereux serial killers ?
Aujourd'hui, on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi les requins nous rendent marteau.
Les requins sont arrivés sur Terre, bien avant nous.
On estime qu'ils sont apparus il y a 400 millions d'années,
soit plus de 150 millions d'années avant les dinosaures.
Ils ont survécu à 4 extinctions de masse.
Actuellement, il en existe environ 500 espèces, très différentes.
Elles peuplent tous les océans, les mers chaudes et froides,
et vivent près de la surface ou dans les profondeurs.
Le plus petit c'est le requin chat pygmée, il ne dépasse pas 15 centimètres.
Quant au plus grand,
c'est celui-ci : le requin baleine,
c'est aussi le plus gros poisson du monde.
Enfin, ça, c'est une miniature.
Les plus gros spécimens mesurent jusqu'à
15 mètres de longueur, environ la taille d'un autobus.
Si vous en croisez un, pas de panique.
Ce requin est parfaitement inoffensif,
il ne se nourrit que de planctons, d'algues et de tout petits poissons.
Côté taille, seul le mégalodon aurait pu rivaliser avec lui.
Un véritable monstre des mers qui a disparu,
heureusement, il y a 3,6 millions d'années.
Il y a quelques mois,
une fillette américaine a retrouvé, sur une plage du Maryland,
une dent de mégalodon fossilisée : elle mesure 12 centimètres de long.
Regardez, la différence avec celle d'un grand requin blanc
qui compte parmi les plus gros spécimens vivants.
On pense que les plus grands mégalodons pouvaient mesurer
jusqu'à 20 mètres de longueur.
Et, contrairement au requin baleine c'est un redoutable prédateur.
J'aurais pas aimé le croiser celui-là, hein.
Il fout une méga trouille.
Chez les requins, l'habit ne fait pas le moine.
Celui-ci, par exemple, le squalelet féroce
qui mesure dans la nature à peine 50 centimètres,
est beaucoup plus susceptible de vous attaquer que l'énorme requin baleine.
Le requin du Groenland, lui, détient un autre record,
c'est le vertébré qui vit le plus longtemps.
Certains spécimens seraient âgés de plus de 400 ans.
Vous l'avez compris, les requins constituent une famille très variée.
En revanche, du point de vue anatomique, ils ont tous un point commun :
ils possèdent un squelette cartilagineux,
ce qui les distingue des autres poissons
dont le squelette est constitué d'arêtes et parfois d'os.
Leur mode de reproduction est lui aussi très particulier.
Certains requins sont ovipares,
ils pondent des œufs dans les fonds marins, comme la plupart des poissons.
C'est le cas de la "roussette" que l'on croise fréquemment en Méditerranée.
D'autres sont ovovivipares,
leurs œufs se développent dans le corps de la femelle et y éclosent.
C'est le cas du "requin taureau".
Lors d'une plongée, il y a quelques années, j'en ai croisé un, enfin une, avec son petit.
Enfin, il existe quelques espèces vivipares
comme le requin gris de récif ; comme chez les mammifères,
les petits requins grandissent dans le ventre de leur mère
à laquelle ils sont reliés par un cordon.
Mais ce qui est le plus remarquable chez les squales, c'est la peau.
Elle est constituée de millions de denticules, de petites écailles
en forme de V qu'on appelle écailles placoïdes.
Elles favorisent l'écoulement de l'eau en la canalisant,
ce qui réduit les frottements et renforce l'hydro-dynamisme de l'animal.
Grâce à cela, ils peuvent se déplacer rapidement.
Le requin mako, par exemple,
peut atteindre la vitesse
de 70 kilomètres par heure.
Cette hydro-dynamisme a inspiré
les ingénieurs
qui ont synthétisé la peau de requin et l'ont testé
sur le fuselage des avions.
Résultat :
moins de frottements de l'air, moins d'énergie nécessaire
pour faire voler l'appareil et donc un petit peu moins de kérosène utilisé.
Mais les particularités des requins ne s'arrêtent pas là.
En 400 millions d'années d'évolution, ces animaux se sont dotés
d'un véritable arsenal pour chasser.
Leur arme principale, c'est l'ouïe.
Elle est si fine qu'ils peuvent repérer des proies à plus d'un kilomètre.
Ils sont aussi dotés d'un odorat exceptionnel.
Les requins possèdent 2 narines indépendantes qui détectent
les protéines qui se trouvent dans le sang
et même dans les excréments des poissons.
Cela leur permet de repérer une goutte d'hémoglobine
dans plus de 4,6 millions de litres d'eau.
C'est l'équivalent de 2 piscines olympiques.
Pour détecter leurs proies,
ces redoutables prédateurs ont un truc en plus :
les ampoules de Lorenzini.
Elles se situent, ici, sur le museau et autour des yeux.
On dirait des petits points noirs.
Ce sont des capteurs sensoriels
qui détectent les champs électriques générés par les autres poissons.
C'est une sorte de sixième sens qui permet aux requins de dénicher
les proies cachées dans le sable ou dans les eaux troubles.
Vous voyez, ces super poissons sont très bien équipés et parmi eux,
certains ont des caractéristiques propres encore plus étonnantes.
Le requin baleine dont nous avons parlé tout à l'heure,
possède de tout petits yeux très fragiles.
Et pour les protéger, il n'a pas de paupières mais des dents.
C'est pour mieux nous dévorer des yeux.
Les dents, c'est sans doute ce qui nous effraie le plus chez les requins.
Elles sont très aiguisées
et peuvent atteindre 7 centimètres de long chez le requin blanc.
Leur particularité, c'est qu'elles tombent et se remplacent constamment.
Les requins peuvent perdre,
tenez vous bien, jusqu'à 30 000 dents au cours de leur vie.
En fait, on le voit très bien sur cette mâchoire,
les dents sont disposées sur plusieurs rangées,
les unes derrière les autres
et elles avancent comme sur un tapis roulant.
Plus surprenant encore,
les scientifiques ont découvert récemment que les requins
ont probablement les dents les plus saines du règne animal.
Leur revêtement extérieur contient du fluorure,
un produit actif que l'on retrouve dans la plupart de nos dentifrices.
Alors, avec des chicots pareils,
doit-on considérer les requins comme d'impitoyables serial killers ?
Eh bien, pas vraiment.
La plupart d'entre eux ne représente aucun danger pour l'homme.
Nos craintes reposent uniquement sur leur apparence.
Parmi les 500 espèces de requins répertoriées,
la quasi-totalité est inoffensive pour les humains.
Seules 5 espèces présentent un danger pour l'homme :
le requin tigre, le requin bouledogue,
ce sont ces 2 espèces qui rôdent autour de l'île de La Réunion,
le requin marteau, le requin océanique et le grand requin blanc.
En 2022, on a compté 57 morsures
spontanées de requins, c'est-à-dire non provoquées par l'homme.
C'est le chiffre le plus bas depuis 10 ans.
Parmi ces attaques, 5 ont été mortelles,
mais il s'agit presque toujours d'un malentendu.
Si certains spécimens s'attaquent à l'homme,
c'est parce qu'ils se sentent menacés
et qu'ils veulent défendre leur territoire.
Dans ce cas, on parle de morsure de défense,
elles sont généralement superficielles.
Le requin ne cherche absolument pas à manger l'humain,
en général,
il le relâche rapidement.
C'est ce qui arrive dans 95% des attaques.
En revanche, et c'est nettement plus rare,
il peut arriver que le requin
considère l'homme comme une proie potentielle
parce qu'il l'a confondu avec un autre animal,
un phoque ou une tortue, par exemple.
On parle alors de morsure de maladresse,
il mord pour se nourrir.
Les morsures sont alors très profondes
et entraînent de graves blessures, voire la mort.
Mais ces attaques mortelles sont extrêmement rares.
Selon des chercheurs de l'Université de Floride,
la probabilité d'être mordu par un requin
et de ne pas survivre à la morsure
n'est que d'une chance sur 3,7 millions.
Vous avez plus de risques d'être frappé par la foudre.
Ok, ok. Les requins ne sont pas des mangeurs d'hommes,
mais alors pourquoi on a une dent contre eux ?
La peur des requins ne date pas d'hier.
Au Vᵉ siècle, avant Jésus-Christ, l'historien grec Hérodote
décrivait déjà des attaques de squales sur des naufragés en Méditerranée.
Avec le début des grandes découvertes au XVᵉ siècle,
les marins traversent les océans
et rencontrent des espèces de requins
inconnues jusqu'alors.
Sur la base de leurs récits, de nombreuses peintures et gravures
représentent l'animal comme une véritable machine à tuer.
Au XXᵉ siècle, cette peur s'enracine à la suite d'une
série d'attaques qui a eu lieu en 1916 aux États-Unis.
Un requin remonte de Floride jusqu'au New Jersey,
où il tue 4 personnes en une dizaine de jours.
Ce terrible fait divers inspire un best seller publié en 1974,
aussitôt adapté au cinéma par un certain Steven Spielberg.
Il s'agit bien sûr des "Dents de la mer".
L'histoire est toute simple un grand requin blanc terrorise
les eaux d'une station balnéaire américaine en faisant plusieurs victimes.
Un petit groupe d'hommes part alors à sa recherche afin de l'éliminer
mais là, les chasseurs vont devoir faire face à un véritable monstre.
En 1975, le film écrase tout au box office
mais le revers de la médaille est terrible pour les requins.
La squalophobie se répand sur toute la planète, du jour au lendemain,
les requins endossent une image de mangeur d'hommes.
Steven Spielberg, dit-on, regrette terriblement,
il n'avait pas l'intention de ternir la réputation des requins.
Il voulait juste faire un bon film et sur ce plan, c'est plutôt réussi.
Alors une bonne fois pour toutes,
non, les requins ne sont pas des monstres sanguinaires.
En réalité, ce grand prédateur
qui trône au sommet de la chaîne alimentaire
est aussi une proie pour l'homme.
Chaque année, tenez vous bien, on tue 100 millions de requins.
Ce sont eux qui devraient avoir peur de nous et pas l'inverse.
Ils sont essentiellement victimes du "shark finning",
une pratique qui consiste à les capturer
pour découper leurs nageoires, en particulier l'aileron.
Cette partie du corps de l'animal
est très prisée dans la cuisine d'Asie du Sud-Est
mais aussi en Amérique du Nord et même en Espagne.
Les ailerons de requin se négocient jusqu'à 500€ le kilogramme,
mais une fois amputés,
les requins sont rejetés vivants à la mer, où ils agonisent lentement.
L'animal est aussi chassé pour ses dents et pour sa peau,
qui sert à fabriquer du cuir, son huile de foie
qui est utilisée notamment pour ses propriétés anti-inflammatoires.
Et, quand ils ne sont pas tués volontairement, de nombreux requins
sont pris par accident dans les filets de la pêche industrielle.
Enfin, comme si cela ne suffisait pas, ils sont bien entendu
victimes de la pollution des océans, comme tous les animaux marins.
À l'arrivée, les dégâts sont considérables.
On estime que les populations de requins
ont diminué de 70% depuis 1970.
C'est une véritable catastrophe écologique car la plupart des espèces
sont indispensables à l'autorégulation de l'écosystème.
Alors, arrêtons de les chasser et protégeons-les plutôt.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
et que vous porterez un regard différent sur ces animaux.
Merci d'être allé jusqu'au bout de cette vidéo,
c'est le meilleur soutien que vous pouvez apporter à la chaîne.
À dimanche prochain,
chers épicurieuses et épicurieux.